why is Donald Trump so interested in
punishing the Islamic Republic of Iran
[Music]
if you've seen the previous two videos
in the series you might believe that
he's interested in raising oil prices
helping as Saudi friends or just showing
the European Union who's boss
[Applause]
but here's another hypothesis what if
Donald Trump is actually getting after
the ends of authoritarian rule in Iran
this is not a stupid theory Iran is that
the edge of economic collapse
anti-government protests are frequented
unlike other countries in the region
Iran does have a secular liberal and
democratic opposition
this means you don't need to wage a real
war to bring democracy to this country
choking regime financially could be
enough
[Music]
this plan actually works Donald Trump
could even be looking at a Nobel Peace
Prize not only that it would make a
bomber look dumb and Trump would win the
2020 election for sure but what if it
doesn't turn out as well as he plans
what if the ayatollah regime is not as
weak as he thinks can trump win the bet
well this video it covers all of that
[Applause]
Iran is the man America loves to hate of
course the White House claims that the
nuclear sanctions are not meant to
topple the regime but is that really
true
[Music]
White House National Security Advisor
John Bolton says the United States is
not seeking to topple Iran's government
but says Washington does want
authorities in Tehran to change their
behavior the truth is for decades
America has been trying to do everything
possible to curb the ayatollahs power
for example have you ever heard of Radio
Free Europe during the Cold War the
American Congress created this radio
station to spread anti-communist
messages into the Soviet Union today
this radio still exists indeed they have
their offices very close to where I am
recording this video in Prague in the
Czech Republic and guess what this radio
has a whole department just devoted to
Iran they broadcast news in the Farsi
language to spread anti Ayatollah
messages inside the country
what does this mean this means that
Washington is most definitely interested
in a regime change in Tehran but one
thing it really badly is one thing
whether it's actually possible is quite
another so the question that might be in
your mind right now is is Iran really
that bad of a dictatorship I mean at the
end of the day they've got elections
they've got political parties right well
yes and also no yeah it is true the
Iranians can vote for the president but
the actual person in charge is the
supreme leader Ayatollah Khamenei for a
better understanding how many chooses
most of the ministers and has the
ultimate word on International Affairs
and many of the important laws
[Music]
oh and of course it goes without saying
the political dissidents are absolutely
prosecuted and often killed by the
government in fact despite having some
opposition movements there are almost no
important leaders why well that's
because they're all dead imprisoned or
exiled though what happens with the pro
system political forces well rather than
political parties we should talk about
the different factions on one hand we
have the so-called hardliners hardliners
support the system created by Khomeini
to the letter religious law and
state-led economy then we have the
Reformers who want to change the regime
from the inside as you can imagine that
this faction is losing power nowadays
finally we have the pragmatists whose
most important representative would be
the current president Hassan rouhani
pragmatists lies somewhere in between
the hardliners
and the Reformers they want some
economic reforms better relations with
the West but also want to retain
religious control over the political
system and here we have the second
question is it really possible for this
whole political system to fall apart
well there is a chance you see when an
economy is doing well it's easy to keep
an authoritarian system going many
citizens are pretty much happy to say
yeah I'll trade a bit of freedom if I
get some welfare but Iran has spent too
much time without welfare Iranian
currency the rial is devaluing every
single day and this has led to brutal
inflation some non official estimates
claim that Iran will have more than a
hundred percent inflation rate this year
that means that some prices change on a
daily basis many foods like chicken are
starting to become scarce and there are
more and more people living below the
poverty line
[Music]
even with the government privatizations
the economy is a mess
we're already told you right here on
visual politic at the beginning of the
year 2018 started with massive protests
against the rahani government and many
of those protesters were young
university students who wanted a shift
in the system a shift to a system that's
democratic that's secular and liberal
but the question that the real question
here is is all of this enough to cause
regime change well today we're going to
answer that question but before we do
let's take a look back at the history
[Music]
the praetorian guard in the in 1979 the
Islamic Revolution started in Iran the
Supreme Leader back then was the
Ayatollah Khomeini and he knew that the
army might the Train at any moment
[Music]
after decades of serving the sharra
Ferger it was hard for them to change
their loyalties overnight this is why in
order to avoid a coup d'etat company
created his own parallel army this is
how the hik Revolutionary Guard was
created it's a sort of modern-day
Praetorian Guard designed to preserve
the Islamic Republican system in the
beginning all the members were
volunteers but things changed in the
eighteen
[Music]
back then Iran started a war with Iraq
and who did they send to the front of
course they sent these Praetorians who
are willing to do anything for their
cause
and you know what in times of warfare
there's always not for money for more
weapons this is how the Islamic
Revolutionary Guard gained a lot more
influence and certainly more weaponry
and experience by the end of the
iran-iraq war this Praetorian Guard
already had more than 130,000 soldiers
plus many other smaller cores that
depended on them
[Music]
today this Revolutionary Guard has its
own intelligence service parallel to the
government's Ministry of intelligence
and they can imprison people and
investigate them without even reporting
to the authorities in other words they
are the cornerstone of the Islamic
Revolution but then again they do have
this parallel system and well why are
they important
you
[Music]
well the truth is as far as the economy
goes it's hard to create an alternative
to the system if you have an elite core
spying on any would-be political
activist and yeah we really are talking
about an elite core here they're
perfectly trained for hybrid warfare
they fought in many other wars such as
in Syria Iraq and even in Afghanistan
and all of the experts say their
training is world-class
[Music]
they might be wondering I mean we talked
about weapons how do they buy weapons I
mean if Iran is so isolated from the
international market how on earth is
that possible well the truth is that for
decades Iran has had its own weapon
manufacturing industry yeah you heard
that right
they use Chinese and Russian designs but
the manufacturing is all done in Iran so
now of course the question becomes when
they be affected by these economic
sanctions I mean at the end of the day
if Iran has no money there's God won't
be able to buy bullets and weapons right
well dear viewer the reality is nothing
could be further
[Music]
external pressure and black a foreign
competitors will most likely help the
IRGC further consolidate its grip over
Iran's economy Ali al phony Arab Gulf
states Institute in Washington the
better understanding a big portion of
Iran's economy is in the Revolutionary
Guards hands they own many state
monopolies including oil companies
refineries and real estate firms for
example 51 percent of Iran telecom
belongs to them add to this the fact
they pay almost no taxes and you have
completely self sustainable economics
with a parallel army that's so well
maintained it's hard to have regime
change well but if you thought this was
the only asset that the ayatollahs have
well you'd be wrong and now you're gonna
see why
China comes to the rescue
we've said this many times in this three
video series China will keep buying oil
from Iran they just can't stop doing
this China needs a lot of oil and for
years Iran has been their sixth most
important supplier we're talking about
more than 800,000 barrels that come from
Iran every single day with these numbers
it's really hard to change providers and
yeah I know what you're thinking
probably right now you've probably seen
those previous videos and you're
thinking well America's got that secret
weapon that's going to keep countries
from buying Iranian oil as we talked
about in the last video basically no
tanker can dock in a harbor if it's not
covered by an insurance company and most
of the insurance companies well they're
European or American so now the question
comes is how does China buy oil from
Iran with this problem well check this
out
[Music]
exclusive China shifts to Iranian
tankers to keep oil flowing amid US
sanctions yeah you have that right
without insurance companies Iran will
take care of the transport and bear all
of the risk and this well this is pretty
great for the people receiving the oil
before they'd have to worry about
maintenance but now Iran pays they'd
have to worry about a ship not reaching
its destination don't worry
Iran's paying ship sinks in the sea
something terrible happens again
Iran pace but this is still not the
whole story
think about it if the rest of the world
is going to stop investing in Iran what
do we have left
exactly we've just freed up space for
China's money
hence news like this
[Music]
Chinese firm to invest two billion
dollars in oil refinery in Iran yeah
yeah you know that right China is taking
advantage of the void other companies
have all left in fact they are even
buying the investments of the European
companies of mate for example this total
the French oil company in 2016 they
started building what was meant to be
the biggest gas field on the planet
now with Trump sanctions chances are
they're going to have to retire this
project
guess who's ready oh yes well China this
summer 2018 the China Development Bank
announced that they will provide more
than 15 billion dollars in loans for all
kinds of projects and you might wonder
in the grand scheme of things is this a
lot of money or not so much well it has
already helped to start building five
brand new hospitals then what about
other companies row when I told you that
Iran is one of the biggest car
manufacturers in the region well one of
the main brands there is cyber they've
already signed a joint venture with
another Chinese company called
brilliance but this this is just the
beginning what's the most ambitious
project currently going on from China
well yeah that's the one belt one road
project this the New Silk Road that Xi
Jingping wants to build
[Music]
chyna eyes iran as important belt and
road hub so far they've already started
to renovate several railroads the idea
is to connect the main Iranian cities
with high-speed train so that they can
transport goods now you might be
wondering well why I ran some importance
well just have a look at this map and
you'll understand
[Music]
imagine a train full of mobile phones
traveling from China going through
Central Asia and then going from Iran to
Turkey it looks like the perfect route
for China to send mobile phones to
Europe right now of course this is just
one idea so far Chinese businesses are
already facing many issues in Central
Asia but this is definitely a matter for
another video
the truth is China is starting to invest
heavily in Iran does this mean that Xi
Jingping will save Iran's economy of
course not but will this be enough for
the regime to survive well just maybe
and this explains why in recent years
the political relations between these
two countries are becoming more and more
fluid
[Music]
xi Jinping halts tax with president
Hassan Rowhani of Iran so now is your
turn
do you really think that Trump's
sanctions will help end the ayatollah
regime well please do leave your answers
in the comment section below and if you
want to dive deeper into all of the
caveats of nuclear sanctions you can
check out the whole series we've
published there are two parts previous
to this one also do visit the reconsider
media or web site there the podcasts
that provided the voices in this episode
that we're not mine
do not forget to subscribe to visual
politic click on the bell icon as well
so you don't miss any of our posts and
if you like this video you know give us
a thumbs up and as always I'll see you
next time and if you want to learn more
about politics and hear more of my
lovely voice don't forget to check out a
reconsider podcast at reconsider
media.com when we consider as a podcast
that challenges you to reconsider your
views by providing context but we don't
do the thinking for you
[Music]